as march madness wraps up the ncaa is
now at the center of a case
that could change the way student
athletes are compensated
student athletes are not paid during
march madness they instead receive
scholarships for school
well now former athletes men and women
are fighting to remove a cap on
compensation
it would give them additional
educational benefits like computers
science equipment and musical
instruments i don't think there's a fan
out there who doesn't think
it would be okay if the coaches made a
few
million dollars less and these athletes
could get things
like graduate school scholarships and
everything else that other students can
get
so the ncaa argues that expanding
benefits could lead to abuse
it says it is currently in the process
of changing the rules
that would allow athletes to earn money
outside of their scholarships
by profiting profiting rather from their
own names
images and likeness the court is not
expected to issue its ruling
until late june